AS WE GO TO NEXT GAME HASHBAD,
HASHBAD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THIS IS HASHTAG BREAKING.
ONE-TIME LEGIT NEWS SITE CNN DOT
COM POSTED A YEAR-END LSITICLE
CALLED 13 HASHTAGS THAT CHANGED
THE WORLD IN 2014.
IT FOCUSED ON THE MORE NOBLE
SOCIAL MOVEMENTS OF THE YEAR,
LIKE YES ALL WOMEN OR ICE BUCKET
CHALLEGE.
BUT WE COULDN'T HELP BUT
NOTICE, CNN,YOU DIDN'T FORGOT
AND OF @MIDNIGHT'S GODDAMN
HASHTAGS.
I MEAN,ARE YOU SAYING WE
DID NOT CHANGE THE WORLD WITH
HASHTAG #POOPMOVIES OR
#SCHLONGSONGS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING, CNN?
WELL, [BEEP] YOU.
HASHTAG #[BLEEP]YOU.
COMEDIANS, I WANT TO GIVE US
MORE HASHTAGS YOU USED THIS YEAR
THAT DIDN'T CHANGE ANYTHING.
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
ALICE.
>> ALRIGHT.
HASHTAG #YESALLLADIESATTHECLUB.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
MATT BRAUNG.
>> HASHTAG# RUMP-SHAKER-BED-
BREAKER-AND-PROUD-DAD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> HASHTAG #ARABSPRINGBREAK.
>> Chris: HEY, POINTS.
MIKE LAWRECE.
>> HASHTAG #KIMJONGUNFRIENDME.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MATT.
>> HASHTAG
#CHARLESISSTILLINCHARGE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE
>> HASHTAG #MICEBUCKETCHALLENGE.
FOR CATS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MIKE.
#NOTALLBEARDEDDUCKCALLERS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALICE.
>> HASHTAG #FOLLOWBACKTOMYLAYER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MIKE LAWRENCE.
>> HASHTAG
#OBAMACAREQUICKANDEASY.
>> Chris: OH. LIKE THAT HASHTAG.
MATT.
>> HAHTAG
#GAYALLDAYFORPAYBUTNOTATNIGHT.
>> Chris: POINTS.